i'm delighted to welcome you all
to the 26th united nations climate
change conference
and it is perhaps fitting that you have
come together in glasgow
once heartland of the industrial
revolution
but now a place to address climate
change
this is a duty i'm especially happy to
discharge
as the impact of the environment on
human progress
was a subject close to the heart of my
dear late husband prince philip the duke
of edinburgh
i remember well
that in 1969
he told an academic gathering
if the world pollution situation is not
critical at the moment
it is as certain as anything can be that
the situation will become increasingly
intolerable within a very short time
if we fail to cope with this challenge
all the other problems will pale into
insignificance
it is a source of great pride to me
that the leading role my husband played
in encouraging people to protect our
fragile planet
lives on through the work of our eldest
son charles and his eldest son william
i could not be more proud of them
indeed i have drawn great comfort and
inspiration
from the relentless enthusiasm of people
of all ages
especially the young
in calling for everyone to play their
part
in the coming days the world has the
chance to join in the shared objective
of creating a safer stabler future for
our people
and for the planet on which we depend
none of us underestimates the challenges
ahead
but history has shown
that when nations come together in
common cause
there is always room for hope
working side by side
we have the ability to solve the most
insurmountable problems
and to triumph over the greatest of
adversities
for more than 70 years i have been lucky
to meet and to know many of the world's
great leaders
and i have perhaps come to understand a
little about what made them special
it has sometimes been observed that what
leaders do for their people today
is government and politics
but what they do for the people of
tomorrow
that is statesmanship
i for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and achieve true statesmanship
it is the hope of many that the legacy
of this summit
written in history books yet to be
printed
will describe you as the leaders who did
not pass up the opportunity
and that you answered the call of those
future generations
that you left this conference as a
community of nations
with a determination
a desire
and a plan
to address the impact of climate
change and to recognize that the time
for words has now moved to the time for
action
of course the benefits of such actions
will not be there to enjoy for all of us
here today
we none of us will live forever
but we are doing this not for ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children
and those who will follow in their
footsteps
and so i wish you every good fortune in
this significant endeavor